[suspenseful music]
♪ ♪
[dramatic whisper]
- What the fuck is this?
- Oh, well, sir, we have been
experiencing an uptick
in reports of employee
depression and aggression.
- So to address the issue,
we implemented Casual Friday,
where employees
can wear jeans once a month.
- Well, that was
a catastrophic mistake.
Just look at that.
I mean, how can someone
lack the shame and dignity
to come into an office
looking like that?
To put on those clothes
and stroll
into a place of business
and think that
that's an acceptable way
to live your life?
- We probably shouldn't tell him
our best lawyer
went insane
and came in shirtless today.
- And what is going on
with those toes?
The second one is too long.
It should be covered.
Why would he subject us to this?
I don't want to see
another human being's foot
for the rest of the day.
- Wow. This is definitely gonna
be a traumatic memory for me.
- Alyssa Armstrong is going to
be here within the hour,
and she represents
Glorious Salvation Ministries,
the largest group
of mega-churches in the country,
and this meeting
was not easy to get.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I had to buy three
of George W. Bush's
dog paintings
to get him to vouch for me.
- [sobs]
- Now, we all know
there's no God,
but there is...
a ton of money
to be made in his name.
So let's try to act
like professionals today.
- [weeping]
- And, John...
put your glasses back on.
You look like
a prepubescent Voldemort.
- Thank you, sir.